hey jb hi kyla drew how are you how are
you i'm well how are you
she looked great yeah yeah you you you
ain't playing you came on this thing
you ain't playing around you look great
look at this yeah
keep it coming keep it coming
i'm not saying everybody else that came
before you but you came in here like i'm
sure you're saying it to everybody
but man i gotta tell you when i saw this
show last night i thought this is such a
great concept but
jamie i mean you talked to your daughter
about putting the most embarrassing
moments
on a show like how did that conversation
even happen
well you know what it's been years me my
relationship
my daughter neighbor actually got in
trouble that's a weird thing
i don't know if something was waiting
down the line for but i never had to say
i know you ain't coming in here late
is that alcohol on your breath who is
this boy lucky
i never had to do any of that but we had
these great sort of embarrassing
heartwarming touching stories
things like me coming to the football
game with a shirt
with her face on it and not the football
team and the whole family
and we're rooting for her as a
cheerleader as opposed to the game so
we've had these ideas for a long time
and then we did live in front of the
studio audience with george jefferson
was like wow
this is still alive and so the netflix
part of it makes sense
and so when we crafted all of these
stories and she was executive producer
that's you know that's poetic for all
the times i've embarrassed her and now
she's
she's my boss and like really putting
the show together like i would do
something i thought was funny
she called out uh that's not funny
you're trying to get cancelled all right
let's let's let's get back
she's keeping it real she's having it's
real i love it hey kyle andrew what do
you you know as a parent
you think that you're cool like you
think you have you think you're with the
kids you know what's happening
so what kind of the cool factor how
would you rate jamie as the father on
the show
from one to ten his character
or a girl yeah jamie oh
oh yeah that is the question
okay let's say jamie himself how's that
oh look go ahead and take a sip of that
of that coffee
um you know
i i'm going to give him an 8 out of 10.
he's pretty cool
the only thing is he needs to learn
more jinzy music if he learns that
10 out of 10 11 out of 10. she was
helping me work him out
yeah dances you know his wit
his his yeah once we get all that
all tuned and you'd be 10 out of 10.
yeah that is cool and for you
have your parents ever embarrassed you
or do you remember a time your parents
embarrassed you
yes yes and yes my mama embarrasses me
this everyday thing literally i recently
started driving
and let's just say it's it's been it's
been
fun it's been fun parking is not my
thing
and my mama makes sure i know it's not
my thing
and jamie you know what's so great about
this show is the conversation
of what's your priority as a parent
you're either
spending too much time in your career
and you kind of forget your kids or are
you for
you know too much time in your kids you
forget your career how do you
tell yourself okay i must stop and now
right now it's focusing on my family
you know it means it means the most
oliver stone taught me something because
i was in a
i was in a situation with my with karen
when she was young
because she was only she about five and
a half when we did any given sunday i
said what do i do
i don't want to be away from my daughter
that long he says bring her to work
bring her just fly her out bring her
here have her on the set
and that taught me a lot like you know
for my kids to be on the set with me
you know my daughter my youngest
daughter has been on a set of django
but she was when she was like five or
something like that watching blood she's
like all the
so not every set you know was probably
the the best
but bringing them to work makes it easy
so now
they see what their dad is doing they
understand
and so now you look at my daughter who's
executive producer of this show my
youngest daughter who's already in the
writer's guild she wrote her own anime
project
so they understand what it is and by
having that now
you don't feel like oh i'm gonna go away
do something be away from a long time
and feel guilty
they're actually there so it's that's
been a plus for me
how's your training going as mike tyson
oh man
listen that's been going on for a long
time
and uh when we when we did the test
shoots where i bulked up
literally as i got dressed i could
literally walk in mike tyson's house and
sit down
and you would he no one would know the
difference and so
i've known mike for a long time and to
hear mike
talk now is the mic that i want people
to see
when i called mike and i said how you
doing i'll praise it to allow my brother
i'm just happy so why just happy because
i don't have any money anymore
i'm like why why does that make you
happy because i don't have any vultures
nobody's trying to take anything from me
so i'm just happy and i just go like
mike i said
this is this is the story it's the epic
triumph it's the epic failure
the epic redemption and then the epic
comeback
and so to have martin scorsese
and to have antoine fuqua at the helm
um it just sets it up for a
very very special project so i i'm
looking forward to getting it all the
way going
can't wait congratulations on the show i
wish i could talk to you guys more about
it but thanks for bringing it to all of
us we need it
thank you
you